there's nothing a nice holiday cheer
let's let's be real questions yeah ask
it I got a real question what bro has
anybody ever seen any pictures of Brian
under 20 or were you made through the 20
I have some [ __ ]
Photoshop I think Brian was artificially
created by the CIA he was made Africa I
now think CIA there too I like that you
were made ascensions you were made after
I cameras you have to say something
really sweet to all of us bro I don't
know as much else conversations just
wasting each other's time with complete
people sometimes two lesbians just
hanging out in Cleveland you don't fill
the air with [ __ ] but Callen wishes
he could read both sometimes I do right
- I just didn't know what you guys were
up to man and a half driver you know
what I don't know how I feel that's fine
hey hey take longer to get [ __ ] up
[Applause]
twenty it could take an hour doesn't
hurt you hey can you bring up a ladder
right picture Brian as a kid blackest
night rolling back to [ __ ] 1930 the
new vaudeville like hey okay more - you
guys are freaking animals man and I love
it
Chris say stop you have to say something
really sweet about each one no we don't
want to do that you keep circling back
yeah yeah yeah we almost let him [ __ ]
talk it you know we're there true alpha
yeah
so dude am i right give me another one
to do what I'll do it okay well we've
got to find it organically but yeah well
[ __ ] find it you little piece of [ __ ]
it's good get there you old but who are
you talking my you got to come harder
than that that was like you like old
[ __ ] but he's big though so he can come
over yeah yeah it was good Brian you
almost hit the [ __ ] mic in your face
there I thought looked pretty [ __ ]
yeah don't don't even know what you're
doing with your microphone today but
yeah yes sweet throat [ __ ] well okay
that's rough two are in the pan there I
am why that's photoshopped it's hundred
percent Photoshop you know how I know
that's Photoshop you know I know that's
what are you that girl I met the other
day she's that age yeah
check out the bangs on Becky yeah that's
patty drink oh my god Brian you were
beautiful young man I was a cute kid
you're still a handsome guy man
yeah Wow look at the [ __ ] in that boy
hey now that right there on the on the
left right there you're going over my
act right no no those are that's mice
now yeah go get press-on eyelashes in
that photo that's long did you get the
brows too yeah I could see bro you know
what you were doing there you are you
know you look very similar when you're
young we did there and then you guys
right like this yeah we really did you
built the same and everything when you
guys were exact Christmas a day see
they're right there I want a piece to
you the [ __ ] up bro you were feeling a
hundred and twenty pounds or your
soldier one fro D huh that looks like oh
and hard a little bit to who is as
skinny I would have [ __ ] I would have
you know what I would have done
scratched you up
Oh to scratch just playing around
that's great young pictures of you they
don't exist I burned them all I've seen
his yearbook and it's a pigeon
I see his yearbook and I saw a photo a
scrapbook of his photos and it's a lot
of him in a musical yeah I didn't use oh
boy what a miracle yeah I did ever seen
a musical by the way there yeah yeah
they're also know what [ __ ] you gotta
sell him again you know I do I see him I
[ __ ] see him you know what sucks
plays [ __ ] plays musicals that's where
it's at man who done plays yeah I [ __ ]
with music what music I go out there
nice and although I did dude there once
was a man who served a term as office
boy when attorneys for a men you know he
cleaned the windows only swept the
floors and polished the handle carefully
that now in the rule of the Queen's I be
that's HMS pinafore [ __ ] y'all dude yeah
dude hey man no advertisement right in
front window and all of a sudden success
coming out of the blue little shop you
know you know when you did that there
was so much spit yeah that's me passion
dude Oh
Newsies I don't know that one what other
musicals did you do you [ __ ] with
non-american grease the Guys and Dolls
would you bring a fork you know I play
to Nicky dude I didn't go mainstream
know you played chemically Kenickie do
it Wow Wow yeah dude yeah yeah everyone
'red I was not a nerd bro every picture
was this nerd this gangly nerd just like
oh like every picture shows up in the
Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat yeah [ __ ]
that was not good you don't know bro see
you lie I've seen it a lot I've never
liked it you Jesus Christ Superstar
tonight and Jesus Christ blasphemous
supastarz Gigi West Side Story Oh No did
you do the three wise men did you do the
uh like the manger scenes that crap oh
no oh the other ones that I did oh you
rent that one I really liked no but you
cat no [ __ ] that one dude I hate cats do
you ever see a Hedwig and the Angry Inch
no never seen cats by the way oh yeah I
want to sorry movie when I was 18 I saw
it on Broadway it's not really it's bad
see ya it was just like oh my god bro
your memories on a long it's dangerous
tunes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]